welcome back to Washington journal for
but the next 55 minutes were joined by
Bob Woodward he's an assistant managing
editor with the Washington Post and he's
also author of this new book maestro
Greenspan's fed and the American boom
here's a cover picture of Alan Greenspan
who is the chairman of the Federal
Reserve and for anybody who doesn't know
who this guy is or why we should care
and technically all he does is to set
the rate the interest rate at which
banks lend each other money overnight
which seems awfully obscure well but it
controls the short-term interest rates
in this country which in the long run
affect the long-term interest rates and
that determines the overall economic
conditions in this country not just what
you're going to borrow money for for
credit cards or mortgages but whether
we're going to have stable growth
whether we're going to avoid recessions
as greenspan has been able to do in the
last ten years so i said about this
project kind of looking at well what's
the most important thing that's happened
in the last ten years in terms out of
the narrowness of washington in politics
but in terms of the lives of real
americans and the answer simply is it's
the economic boom and when you
investigate this or attempt to as a
reporter you find that all roads lead to
greenspan not just in terms of the
interest rate but in terms of the
relationship with the white house on how
much money the federal government is
going to spend in terms of the financial
crises around the globe like Mexico
Korean banks the Russian default Alan
Greenspan is often at the center and
plain the key role you know one of the
things that comes through in your book
is that I think most people who do know
how important he is think of him as
all-knowing and in steely control of the
economy there are several times in the
book where you show how you can be
nervous he can be uncertain he can be
confused he can be totally unsure of
exactly what's going on in what's coming
back in fact during the first months of
his tenure the 1987 stock market crash
his reaction was
to be very nervous and unsure and in
fact he said if you're not nervous you
don't belong here nervousness is part of
this job in the sense that you have to
measure the markets what's going on on
Wall Street what's going on in the most
obscure numbers and the latest Commerce
Department report about the economy
what's going on in terms of the politics
of the White House and the Congress so
idiot it is in it temperamentally it
fits him because he is not he is an
empirical person he will listen to
anybody came in as kind of this classic
Republican conservative inflation hawk
do anything to keep inflation down and
the intellectual journey he has been on
is a very astonishing one to the point
that four years ago he refused to raise
rates because he was the one perhaps as
early as anyone realized that the
economy had shifted into a new economy
that there was an x factor in the
economy which was productivity growth
workers were making more Goods per hour
so we didn't have the inflation fear
that we would normally have under the
conventional models and that was chiefly
responsible for the enormous boom that
we had in the economy well you had to
have Bill Gates and the computer
revolution you had to have no war going
on had to have stable oil prices all
sorts of other factors but in terms I
guess the analogy I would use it's like
riding a bicycle downhill you can go too
fast and crash and you have to apply the
brakes at crucial moments to keep
yourself going down at a steady rate
well in this case it's going up keep the
economy growing at a steady rate and he
he is the guy there publicly or behind
the scenes so often not always but so
often pulling the strings it
it's a very emotional political dramatic
tale want to remind our viewers and our
listeners were dividing up the phone
lines a little differently from the way
we've been doing for most of our
segments a the first line is for those
of you in the eastern and central time
zones you can call in at 20 26 24 1111
mountain and pacific time zone viewers
to 0 to 62 for 1115 those of you in
other countries 2027 376 734 and our
first call comes from Clearwater Florida
one of your readers has read maestro
good morning good morning and I'm as a
pleasure to speak with Bob water and
yourself and incidentally I have the
Bob's book on order I haven't had a
chance to read it yet but I will Bob I
agree with your premise that alan
greenspan is the most influential public
figure in the world today and I wonder
if you take note in your book of the
fact that he is besides being just a
bureaucrat in charge of a government if
you will bureaucracy that he is in fact
leading an ideological revolution if you
recall an Arthur Burns time one of his
predecessors if unemployment went up if
the economy got in trouble government
was supposed to step in and spend money
run deficits perhaps even inflate the
economy from the central bank standpoint
that has all changed and it's been in a
conscious revolution that central banks
and other governments are following
Greenspan to lead on and I wonder how
you would develop that okay well first
of all when you say he's in charge of
the government government bureaucracy
he's chairman of the Federal Reserve on
the key interest rate setting committee
there are 11 other votes they all count
the same what I found is that he is able
to dominate that group and in setting
short-term interest rates really the the
Federal Reserve is in charge of the
sovereign currency in the United States
and they can send interest rates
literally through the ceiling much
higher than they were in the 1970s above
twenty percent a year or they could send
them down virtually 20 but you're
exactly right in terms of I don't know
there it's a new theory in a sense it
goes back to pure it anism in America
only spend what you have and the the
theory is that the government should
only spend what it has and when it runs
a deficit as it did for so long during
the 80s in particular that you have to
get that deficit down because if you do
that you will choke off inflationary
expectations and long-term interest
rates will come down that lowering of
long-term interest rates is the chief
engine for economic growth that
businesses can expand consumers home
homeowners can borrow more and pay less
for it it is the a key ingredient in the
expanding economy that we've had our
next call for Bob Woodward from st.
George Utah good morning ah good morning
I just wanted to say that I need
chairman Greenspan is doing the right
things he's had a pretty good history of
correctness and putting on the brakes
and pulling off the brakes I think it's
great for the economic well-being of
this country in fact as I'm amazed as
some of the insight he had at putting on
the brakes before something happens are
releasing them before something happens
I think it's just great and then one
side comment the history channel has got
a thing I'm a history's greatest
mysteries and I think history's greatest
mysteries who was is deep throat and I
don't expect you to answer that thank
you very much i can i can say that deep
throat is not Alan Greenspan that though
he was working he came to work in the
Nixon White House did just literally in
the last week's of the Nixon
administration he knew nothing about
Watergate in was not in
in any way Greenspan has made a lot of
key judgments what's interesting when
you go into the stories it's not always
as George was suggesting clear what to
do I envy I could get into some of the
specifics if you just take the Mexican
debt crisis of 1994 1995 there was a
secret memo prepared by one key
economist in the Fed saying that if this
Mexican debt crisis gets out of control
it will take two percent off the US
economy's annual growth which would send
the economy close to recession or into
recession so Greenspan and the White
House and the Congress all attacked this
problem the republican-controlled
Congress at this point was feeling it's
oats and just said we are not going to
let the federal government bailout
Mexico turned out there was a fun called
the eckin Stabilization Fund that
allowed literally the executive branch
to loan the money on its own Greenspan
was the key player and kind of cutting
the deal in making the arrangement so
this could be done the Republicans were
going to still squeal in public but in
private Bob Dole who was then Senate
Majority Leader agreed there would not
be a vote to take away the power of the
White House to loan this money to Mexico
it worked out very well Mexico was saved
and this is only kind of one of those
cases where disaster was averted you've
given me a great intro to something that
I wanted to bring up anyway this is a
review from slate about your book and
let me just read it in just your comment
the weirdest moment in the book and
perhaps the closest Woodward comes to
telling us what it is that makes
Greenspan truly different and special as
a scene set in 1994 the details aren't
important but Greenspan must overcome a
consensus among his colleagues to raise
rates by half a point when the Chairman
thinks a quarter points enough Greenspan
who ultimately carries the day at a
crucial
point goes all out making his case and
says quote i am telling you i have a
pain in the pit of my stomach unquote
woodward then writes the pain and the
stomach was a physical awareness
greenspan had experienced many times he
felt he had a deeper understanding of
the issue a whole body of knowledge in
his head in a whole value system then he
was capable of stating at that moment if
he was about to say something it wasn't
right he would feel it before he was
intellectually aware of the problem it
was this physical feeling this sense in
the stomach that he believed kept him
from making dangerous or absurd
statements that might appear on the
front page of the newspapers at times he
found his body sensed danger before his
head as he walked down the street there
would be an approaching car and his body
new to stay out of its way before his
head yeah exactly it's a kind of Sixth
Sense it is if you look at a picture of
Greenspan you see baby seems gloomy and
enigmatic kind of somebody who was going
through life almost mechanically inside
he is constantly churning he is
constantly looking at documents I was
able to trace through some of the
statistics that he gets out of the
Commerce Department the Bureau of Labor
Statistics and so forth in it when he
gets a thick stack like that it's like a
box of chocolates to him he just gobbles
it up probably examines numbers that no
one else in the world sees now the
earlier caller made a very good point
that when you are dealing with inflation
you really are dealing with inflation
expectations it sounds technical and
economists make it sometimes sometimes
incomprehensible but it's very
comprehensible at the Federal Reserve
they don't really have to worry about
what inflation is today what they have
to do is worry about what it's going to
be in nine months or a year because the
impact of interest rates operates with
the lag of six months a year maybe even
18 months so you have to make decisions
shins now about where things are going
to be in about a year and that's a very
difficult intellectual task initially
Greenspan thought he didn't want to be
when is his mentor Arthur Burns was fed
chairman said this is to arcane and
obscure I don't understand this now of
course the task not of predicting the
future with certainty but kind of taking
all of these numbers and forces in
figuring out where they converge and say
aha we need to set interest rates here
either too slow or boost the economy so
is a one tricky game so instead of
watching the size of his briefcase which
is an indicator some people look at we
ought to see what is pepto-bismol bill
yeah that's I mean the pit of the
stomach analogy somebody over at the
Federal Reserve when I was doing
research on this said now when you put
this in the book people are going to
come around here and a and have the kind
of pit of the stomach index what is his
stomach telling him our next call for
Bob Woodward from pensacola florida good
morning good morning and i have not read
mr. wood wood book is yet but i have a
question and what your thoughts on does
mr. greenspan when he's making these
decisions does he look at it in a global
how we stand as a global economy there's
more investments now in Europe which is
not really taking off and do you think
that he considers how he might improve
the European economy for us that are
investing well I mean he can't improve
the European economy but he is somebody
who measures you know what is the
relationship between the euro and the
German mark and the German mark versus
the English pound and so forth he
literally in his office has a computer
program worry monitors these indexes
sometimes every 15 minutes he realizes
as much as anyone that the American
economy exists not in a vacuum but in
this
full system that we have spends a great
deal of time in Switzerland Europe
traveling around the world are getting
to know the central bankers in these on
other countries in the systems that they
have in a sense you if you talk to
economists at all or other people at the
Fed they say when they travel around the
world all the key economists and
financial players in other countries
want to do is how do we get an alan
greenspan somebody here who has that
capacity to seed the large picture and
in make these decisions wisely be
cautiously afraid of Washington your
next good morning good morning I want to
talk a little bit about the federal
reserve system and its chairman whoever
that might be in it's our own Greenspan
now it's always been very troubling to
me because most people just by virtue of
its name assume that the set is a part
of the US government and according to my
research that's not entirely true other
than I understand that the Chairman is
appointed by the government in some
capacity or another with all the power
that the Fed has worldwide it governs
the economy of the world where is the
accountability who does the Fed Alan
Greenspan actually answer to yeah that's
a really important question of first of
all the Federal Reserve and the system
is very much a government agency but it
is an independent agency the president
can't tell them what to do neither than
konkuk in Congress and in fact the
courts have not in in any way
successfully attempted to sect
second-guess their judgment so it's very
it's very much kind of like the Supreme
Court of money interestingly enough and
in surprisingly so Greenspan him
selves being a conservative Republican
is very much aware of how concentrations
of power can be unsafe if they are
unmonitored and not accountable and in
Greenspan's famous 1996 speech about
irrational exuberance as you may recall
when he said there the stock market may
be the victim of irrational exuberance
in that very speech Greenspan said the
the Federal Reserve governors and
himself who are unelected have to be
very very accountable and in what has
happened in Greenspan's tenure is they
are much more open when they make key
interest rate decisions in the past
these were not announced publicly but
simply kind of covertly the changes took
place in the markets of the the big
players on Wall Street detected the
changes first now they publicly announce
them right after the decisions are made
I found it possible to penetrate and
find out how they function the last long
book that has been written about the
federal reserve was written by a former
colleague of mine at the Washington Post
Bill grider and it was called the
secrets of the temple there's still some
secrets there but they're fewer of those
and it is Greenspan leading the charge
to get the information out to the public
himself feeling exactly what you say you
know we need to be accountable and
answerable Hyannis Massachusetts your
next with Bob Woodward good morning good
morning I I have two questions really
one is what involvement specifically did
you have with mr. Greenspan during the
process of developing and writing the
book and the second is we're all
familiar with the work that he does in
the Federal Reserve what does in raising
and lowering interest rates what else is
he responsible for doing what else is a
part of his job
okay first of all as I say in the book
because this is about Washington in
politics and money I don't disclose most
of the sources that I dealt with and
where I got the information I would love
to do that unfortunately to do something
like this that is so contemporaneous
you're never going to get the kind of
real story if you identify your sources
as I was saying earlier in terms of what
Greenspan does he is somebody who has
his tentacles out everywhere for example
early in his tenure he used to
personally call up Jack Welsh the
chairman of General Electric because at
that point in the late 80s Welsh and GE
had a system of measuring what they were
selling what was on their order books
from light bulbs to jet engines that was
a wonderful indicator of the direction
the economy was taking Greenspan has a
network in relationships with people on
the hill with people on Wall Street
people are heads of big companies
somebody who goes around and speaks to
all kinds of groups then in the
international financial arena its
Greenspan who plays often a key role as
the executive branch in the Federal
Reserve and the Congress have to deal
with some like the Asian crisis which
could have sent our economy down into
the toilet literally you find him
playing a very active if not the most
significant role in some of these
actions let me just make one more try on
behalf of that caller anybody who reads
this book has to come away especially
after something with an example I just
read about the feeling in the pit of his
stomach that you must have spent a lot
of time with alan greenspan you know
I've going back to the Watergate
coverage or the books I've done on the
CIA or
the White House the Supreme Court you're
just not going to get high quality
information if you disclose your sources
I make every effort to talk to everyone
involved get as many perspective as
perspectives as possible and you're not
going to get that kind of real account
if you name your sources and I would
love to and you know after people are
deceased I do disclose sources for
instance the book on the Supreme Court
that's got Armstrong and I did five of
the Justice has helped us two of them
powder steward and Lewis Powell ER
deceased and I'd be happy to make my
notes available to anybody about those
discussions our next call for Bob
Woodward from Santiago Chile good
morning good morning morning yes first
of all I would really like to
congratulate c-span for your great
program and mr. would award for his
great journalist career I would I want
him to expand a bit about two questions
that have already been asked but I think
I would the importance that needs to be
a little more addressed the of a deep
impact mr. Greenspan has the whole world
economy that in his hands he real it
already holds the hands and jobs and the
growth of all countries of the world and
that related to the accountability when
did be more and I'm saying in a nice way
more proper to call him instead of
Maestro the great dictator thank you
very much ah well well he doesn't
dictate as I was saying earlier on the
key interest rate setting committee he
only has one of 12 votes they can
outvote him at any point for instance in
in 1996 eight of the 12 Federal Reserve
Bank's actually requested a interest
rate increase and there was a key
meeting Greenspan went into we're
clearly the sentiment was to raise
interest rates
he again almost got down on his knees
and begged them and said don't do it
there is a new economy productivity is
going up one of the governors of the
Federal Reserve Janet Yellen at the time
who's now professor out at Berkeley
actually calculated if there had been a
secret ballot rather than in the
interest rate committee they vote in
it's not secret and each governor will
say I go with the Chairman's
recommendation or I don't he won I think
11 of the votes including his own but
Janet Yellen calculated that if it had
been a secret ballot where you didn't
have to identify yourself as voting
against the Chairman he would have lost
probably nine to three that he only
really had three people committed but
because he so dominates because people
trust him they go along with him but
when you see the internal dynamic here
that I've tried to portray you realize
that he's not dictating anything that
others can can go their way and his
predecessor Paul Volcker had this occur
you talk a lot of in the book about how
deliberately ambiguous he is when he
speaks on deliberately confusing he is
when he's saying things in public you
also mentioned that that confusing
quality of his speech got him into a
little trouble with his now wife Andrea
Mitchell is a correspondent for ABC News
he had to ask her twice to to marry him
I guess yes it's kind of the height of
ambiguous and indirect communication
that when you are talking to somebody
and asking them to marry you they don't
quite understand it but again it's a
sign of his emotional forbearance then
instead of screaming out hey don't you
understand I'm asking you to marry me he
just let it go and then came back again
and failed and finally the third time
said
to her do you want a small wedding or a
large wedding and I think that message
was not missed like a lot of couples in
Washington the journalists married to a
policy maker how do they work it out how
did obviously a lot of what he knows
what he's going to say would be
enormously helpful to her because he
just not tell her to see I don't know
the answer to that but she doesn't tell
or broadcast what she knows this was
tested the day he was appointed by
Ronald Reagan is fed chairman in 1987
andrea mitchell and greenspan were
dating at that point and he knew the
next day there was going to be a
surprise announcement of him is federal
federal reserve chairman incredibly
important news she knew at the night
before and did not leak it to anyone in
fact Jim Baker who was the Treasury
secretary at the time and who was really
Greenspan's godfather and got him the
job said to Greenspan after the
announcement was made he said we were
watching it carefully to make sure it
didn't leak out on NBC News where andrea
mitchell works one more quick question
before we get back to the phones and
that is what is the effect on somebody
in becoming one of the most famous
people in the world here we go from a
guy who was a relatively obscure
economist and he took a job in the
administration and the Ford
administration still pretty obscure now
he's a household word has that changed
him have you known him long enough to
see changes in him well he says to
people that he's an introvert and that
people particularly in Washington who
are dogmatic extraverts almost that
people don't understand the extent to
which he is an introvert so I think he
tends to take it less seriously than
most because I it's something I think he
doesn't really enjoy small talk that
when he's relaxing he does calculus
problem
if you can imagine that he may be the
only person in his 70s who does calculus
problems for relaxation or turns to his
calculator he is a math whiz somebody
who's interested in mathematical
relationships as much as political
relationships to keep sees that
political relationships are often much
more complicated than mathematical ones
there's no sign I see that it's got gone
to his head at the same time is
incredibly intellectually confident
person who does not suffer fools easily
somebody who knows who to deal with and
who not to deal with when a new member
comes on the Senate Banking Committee he
immediately has breakfast with that man
or woman gets to know them because he
realizes that someday maybe someday soon
that person will be chairman in the
Senate Banking Committee or his biggest
critic and when Senator Connie Mack a
Florida who is now leaving the Senate I
came on the Banking Committee he signed
a letter of kind of routine letter to
Greenspan saying you know we're group of
senators were concerned about why he was
doing what he was doing with interest
rates and Greenspan went to Connie Mack
and said you know senator you don't have
to write me a letter you can come see me
anytime you can call me you get me on
the phone other words I am available to
you let's deal personally and directly
with each other he establishes dozens of
those kinds of intimate relationships so
when he goes up to testify in congress
he knows all those people who are asking
him questions or all of the key ones and
the Banking Committee is important
because because they have oversight over
the Federal Reserve they hold the
hearings
and there's some other committees that
do and of course the Senate Banking
Committee has to confirm Greenspan and
they confirmed him four times four for
four years terms Arnett's call for bob
woodward from warren michigan good
morning hi mr. Woodward I really
appreciate your insightful comments on
the election as to it work but the
moderator already addressed one of my
questions about the courtship of Henry
Mitchell he got it in there before I
could ask it is kind of a it you really
go wow that's quite a tale yeah so well
that was a minor when I was just
interested in better that was it that
was something you know because he is
ambiguous so that i could see i could
see they're having a problem with but uh
hell we ain't my dad at night but anyhow
of the was the question i got it i think
he gets a little too much credit you
give you know he's federal reserve he's
on the margins with the interest rates
and everything as far as the economy
goes but the real impetus for the
economy was the fed to budget which is
1.7 trillion dollar budget and you're
talking almost and the last seven years
President Clinton dominated that budget
he got everything he wasn't on all seven
years and that 70 in and that's about
eighty percent of that deficit Dustin
repackaged and if you look at all the
industrial countries every single one
they didn't follow Greenspan's lead they
follow President Clinton's lead England
got rid of their conservative but Blair
in Germany got rid of theirs and put
replaced coal plants replace ters Italy
replaced us every single country that's
as it falls it they follow President
Clinton's lead not Greenspan's lead okay
what I write about in some very intimate
detail in the book is the relationship
between Greenspan and Clinton and you
find that Greenspan played an absolutely
critical role in convincing Clinton of
the importance of lowering the federal
deficit to the point that we now have
the
surpluses that we have there was a wrote
a book in 1994 called the agenda about
the making of clinton's economic policy
and you find greenspan plays a critical
role but within the White House there
was a war for President Clinton soul
about do you reduce the deficit or is
lots of the populists advisors to
Clinton argued no we need more social
programs we need to spend federal money
on investments in job retraining and so
forth essentially the grievance band bob
rubin lloyd bentsen wing of clinton's
advisers one out so it's not as if
clinton did this all on his own he
deserves an immense amount of credit the
person to give Bill Clinton the most
credit is Alan Greenspan Greenspan
believes the Clinton displayed the kind
of totally rare political courage in
putting forth his deficit reduction plan
in 1993 which was really the beginning
of the process that we've gone through
over the last eight or nine years to get
the federal deficit down program note
for our viewers tomorrow morning on
washington journal bob novak syndicated
columnist with the chicago sun-times
Frank Rich a columnist with the New York
Times and a tour of the Smithsonian's
american history museum exhibit about
submarines used in the Cold War our next
call for Bob Woodward comes from Phoenix
Arizona good morning good morning mr.
Woodward I am thrilled to be talking to
you I have two questions how much of a
part did Robert Rubin play and
Greenspan's economic boom and a second
question which I am very concerned about
is when the rehnquist court overruled
the Arkansas home judge I felt then
that Rehnquist and Bennett were in
cahoots and now that they've taken on
this case down here are you going to do
any book on this Rehnquist court because
I know it's going to go for Bush thank
you okay well if you know that in the
election that the rehnquist court is
going to go for Bush then you know more
than anybody else I think there's no way
to predict it all what's going to happen
and I think it's quite possible as the
Supreme Court is now wrestling with this
[ __ ] this issue they do not know
themselves you asked about Bob Rubin
which is a very good question Ruben was
head of the National Economic Council
for Clinton when Clinton first came in
and then Reuben became Treasury
secretary at the beginning of 1995 and a
lot of people give Rubin a credit for
what occurred he deserves an immense
amount what's interesting to me in
telling this tale from the Greenspan
perspective is the relationship between
Greenspan and Ruben it was so close the
Greenspan actually felt that it was it
is if the two of them and Clinton and
other people in the Clinton
administration were working for the same
firm and I detailed the conversations in
the decisions and how Rubin and
Greenspan worked together and it's one
of the truly unique and successful Fed
Chairman secretary of the Treasury
relationships Larry Summers the Treasury
secretary now has very much the same
relationship with Greenspan there's an
interesting quote on the back yearbook I
reappointed him and he disappointed me
from President George Bush this is a
reminder that in the view of president
bush and some other people that
Greenspan is not infallible that in fact
in 1990 1991 his keeping interest rates
high was responsible for at least in
part for the recession the 90
ninety-one recession what do you think
of that a and B we're in another we're
in a similar situation today where we're
aiming for a soft landing they've raised
rates six times from june of last year
to may of this year could we could we be
in a situation where greenspan could be
fallible again well greenspan or anybody
doing this can be fallible in the case
of president bush from 89 to the end of
beginning of 93 when clinton took over
greenspan during most of that period was
lowering interest rates president bush's
objection was the Greenspan was not
doing it fast enough or that the
increments were not large enough when
you look at this the idea that
Greenspan's failure to make the interest
rates low enough fast enough to make the
recovery visible in 92 was somehow
Greenspan's fault I do not buy that at
all President Bush was running for
re-election if people recall that
campaign he he appeared to be and
whether this is fair to him or not I
don't know he appeared to be out of
touch he appeared to be somebody who did
not understand the economic pain that
lots of people were still going through
is they were coming out of the 90 91
recession I think if Greenspan had
lowered interest rates too much too fast
we might have had a runaway economy we
might have inflation could have gotten
out of control in in doing what
Greenspan did during this period I think
he laid the conditions by keeping the
inflation under control for the boom
that we then later experience so I
really don't buy that and what about
today today is a really interesting
question in in in many ways I have
attempted in this book to me it's kind
of about your money you not just
investments people might have
but jobs they might have the overall
economic conditions that we live in and
you can see what the factors are
economics is often thought of is dreary
and boring and full of absurd
terminology and I think it's all of the
above I've tried to decode it here so
you can understand what's going on and
what's going on now in 1999 in earlier
this year Greenspan as you said raised
rates the short term interest rate to
try to cool down the economy so instead
of having a astronomical high and then a
recession that we moderate growth so it
is stable and that prices are stable
there are indications that this may work
there are also indications that we're
going to have a hard landing that maybe
the economy is slowing down too fast
very important theory in all of this is
you have to raise interest rates before
the economy gets too hot to kind of slow
it down also conversely in Greenspan is
indicated he somewhat agrees with this
you also have to lower interest rates
before the economy starts to tank in
order to keep things stable so we may
find a pre-emptive or early lowering of
interest rates sometime next year before
it's absolutely evident that the economy
is grinding into some sort of halt or
overall growth is sinking our next call
for Bob Woodward author of Maestro comes
from Appleton Wisconsin good morning
good morning I was wondering mr.
Woodward if you talk to mr. Greenspan
within the past two weeks and know if
given his affinity for mathematical
calculations of Statistics has any
opinion who really won the florida
election testable anomalies politics
aside i have not and i suspect no one
would really get a statistical or
political answer
from Greenspan on that just because he
has to realize what hot topic it is but
it is interesting in the the if you're
at all familiar with the theories of
large numbers and what's going on here
in Florida with six million votes in a
way any recount by machine or hand is an
approximation that there isn't you know
maybe the Lord knows exactly how many
people voted or intended to vote for
gore and Bush and could give us a number
but any effort that anyone is going to
get whether it's looking at ballots or
whether it's running them through the
Machine again or through lawsuits or
decisions you just they're all
approximations and with it's so close if
it's it's hard to figure out what that
number is that's a smooth a Segway as
I've ever heard from monetary policy to
politics okay so let me take advantage
of it and ask this and this is Robert
Novak column and of course Robert Novak
will be on washington journal tomorrow
morning and let me just read you a few
paragraphs and get your comment but
serious fed watchers believe that Alan
Green I'm sorry that Alan Greenspan is
secretly rooting for Al Gore against
george w bush a preference with deep
implications for the real economy the
warmth of Greenspan's eight-year
relationship with the clinton
administration is matched by the
frostiness of his relationship with the
bush family the next president will name
for of the federal reserve seven
governors in a bush appointed board
imperils Greenspan's mastery as a superb
Washington political chess player the
Chairman's well aware of the danger
posed by a bush victory and then let me
go on and read just another paragraph
down here if we get it on the Robo cam
he has few critics and hardly any
enemies this is Greenspan with one big
exception high officials in President
George Bush's administration still raged
that clinton was elected in 1992 because
of Greenspan's tight money policy at the
Fed we've just talked about that
intended or otherwise revenge could be
exercised by the Sun even though george
w bush's economic advisor lawrence
lindsey is Greenspan's friend and former
colleague at the fed the new republican
president would like would be likely to
name for new governors at the central
bank not nearly so docile
as Greenspan's current associates bob
novak is a excellent reporter and a very
interesting column columnist but I
really disagree with him on this I think
Greenspan had has had this incredible
relationship with Clinton and Clinton's
Economic Advisers those would not be
Gore's advisors necessarily he also and
and the the factor that Novak has left
out here is he is overlooking something
critical one of Greenspan's best friends
somebody's had a 26-year personal
relationship with his dick cheney who's
the vice presidential nominee candidate
perhaps going to be vice president and
cheney and greens man go back to the
Ford White House during the Gulf warm
when Cheney was Secretary of Defense I
write about how Cheney effectively gave
top secret briefings to Greenspan who
was worried about oil prices and the
course and likely outcome in timing of
the Gulf War Greenspan would not take
sides I think maybe personally maybe
with his wife and good friends but I
think he's smart enough to know that he
can build a relationship with a
president george w bush through cheney
and through lindsey or he can build a
relationship with gore and his advisors
or kind of build on the one that he had
with clinton's advisors like if larry
summers stain on his treasury secretary
so a real Novak misses something about
greenspan which i think is critical to
understand and that is greenspan knows
the ups and downs of politics somebody's
in somebody's out and you forge
relationships with
the people who have power who are going
to make decisions but you don't get
involved in the process by which they
acquire power or fail to acquire power
Houston Texas your next with Bob
Woodward author of my straw yes sir good
good day it's privileged what credit do
you allow Greenspan and the
administration for getting through the
Asian and Mexican currency crises and
the collapse of that multi-billion
dollar New York hedge fund a lot I have
sections in the book where you see
exactly what happened in the
behind-the-scenes role the Greenspan
played in the case of the 1998 and this
is a little-known chapter in in
financial history but in after Russia
the Russian default of August 1998 there
was this hedge fund called long-term
capital management up in Connecticut
which had so much money invested in the
international bond market the Russian
default caused many of their investments
to go down they were so positioned in
the market the people that actually the
bond market froze up it was a somewhat
discussed in the press at the time but
the extent to which it had frozen up
people did not understand the button in
the bond market is this kind of giant
hidden market people talk about the
stock market the bond market is much
bigger and many knowledgeable people
feared his long-term capital management
was about to go under it could cause
some sort of chain reaction in the world
economy and really send the United
States economy I into serious problems
Greenspan played a role but the key role
was played by the New York Fed President
bill McDonough who actually got all of
the people who loaned this hedge fund
money together and they bailed the fund
out with with
private money you see in each of these
greens man's reaction in how he weighs
the information and then makes judgments
about what to do and who to support our
next call for bob woodward from
ridgecrest california good morning good
morning I would like to ask the
gentleman is not the Federal Reserve
Bank's 12 of them owned by private
companies are private owned banks and
controlled by stockholders which Nelson
Rockefeller is a stockholder 5,000 plush
chairs and how much is a share of the
Federal Reserve worth and why do we let
them buy our money at the cost of
printing loan it back to the government
at face value and then charges interest
on our own money that just to me is is
just ludicrous and crooked and it was
all contrived by the house of rock child
through Paul Walker and Senator Aldrich
okay thanks going okay well there are
fears about the power that the Federal
Reserve has it's actually controlled
through the government but there is a
concentration of power here that needs
to be watched and I think it tends to be
watched by the press and by the people
who were there who were concerned about
the power that they have because
technically the Federal Reserve could go
around and buy up all the debt in the
world they could buy furniture and
televisions and automobiles legally to
adjust the interest rates they have
never done that I don't think they're
going to do it there chief instrument in
controlling the short term interest rate
is the buying and selling of federal
debt federal bonds but there is an
immense power there I don't see and I
saw no signs that it was operating
conspiratorial a and for the nickel it's
worth I sure looked hard our last call
for Bob Woodward comes from Springfield
Missouri good morning
good morning mr. Woodward I was
wondering I have often wondered this and
perhaps you had some insight into it
when mr. Greenspan is no longer in his
position for whatever reasons what
effect do you think that would have on
our country's economy and I wondered if
anyone's being trained as competent mr.
Greenspan for his position thank you
well you can't be trained for this job
because it is a political appointment
made by the president we don't know who
the president is going to be but
Greenspan's term lasts until two
thousand four so not only is he this
very significant figure of the economic
past he will be a dominant if not the
dominant figure in our economic future
at least until 2000 for it it is an
interesting model to see how he does his
job who the next Fed Chairman is or
Greenspan would be 78 when his term
expires and technically could be
appointed to a fifth term there are
people who have served that long as
chairman of the Federal Reserve in
history I wanted to show our viewers a
picture of if they're worried about Alan
Greenspan's health and vigor here he is
on the tennis court should apparently
still plays on a regular basis he loves
to play tennis and gets exercise you see
him around town he's got you know he's
good there's no middle here that lots of
people that age he's now 74 and people
who deal with them say that there's no
de munition of the intellectual powers
he can still there's no drift eNOS and
somehow by keeping his mind exercise
it's still exercised it still functions
while we got about 30 seconds left quick
question covering Watergate covering the
Florida recount similar utterly
different any lessons to be learned well
in water gated less lasted for two years
in two months let's hope this doesn't
last for two months let alone two years
in two months Bob Woodward author of
Maestro assistant managing editor for
The Washington Post thanks very much for
come
this morning thank you